vous allez voir ces images c'était hanoï
au vietnam une petite fille de deux ans
est tombé de son balcon alors elle est
pas tomber ni du premier étage et du
deuxième étage je crois que c'est du 12e
et regard des images tout s'est bien
terminé comme toujours dans l'émission
regarde un truc dingue
la scène se déroule dimanche dernier
hanoï au vietnam et elle fait froid dans
le dos une petite fille de 3 ans
suspendu dans le vide accroché à son
balcon au 12e étage de son immeuble
alerté un livreur qui étaient garés dans
sa camionnette juste en dessous de la
fillette qui fut lue par lâcher prise
l'homme réussi à amortir la chute avec
son bras miraculée elle est en vie avec
semble-t-il une simple luxation de la
[Applaudissements]
mairie que départ
s'est passé quelque chose il ya pas si
longtemps au quatrième étage de
l'appartement j'habitais il ya un an un
moment un dimanche en temps un coup
qu'est ce qui se passe comme une sorte
d'explosion tu me retourne et le voisin
dio avait glissé de son balcon et il est
tombé sur le capot d'un taxi mais le
gars va très bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la première fois de ma vie j'ai appelé
les pompiers
hallyday
petit numéro peut sauver des vies merci
bonjour
alors si c'est vrai que c'est que j'en
est coincé pas trop vrai que le capot
d'une voiture ont à toi martyr
concernant la
lâcher on a un autre ex à vous montrer
ce qu'on ne s'étant encore beau votre
foi me semble-t-il regardez la scène se
passe en pleine journée un appartement
ravagé par les flammes et deux enfants
de trois et dix ans prise au piège
l'aîné tient à bout de bras son petit
frère il le lâche l'enfant tombe dans le
vide il arrive 20ème au sol sous la
fenêtre une dizaine de jeunes se sont
regroupés pour le réceptionner puis
c'est au tour du plus grand même
scénario même sauvetage un saut de plus
de 10 mètres sans une égratignure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous ne savez pas les jours des trois à
un immeuble en flammes et ça c'est
génial parce que c'est la solidarité
quoi on s'organise et moi je pense qu'on
peut avoir des forces décuplées quand on
sait jamais comment on réagira en fait
alors je me dis pas que je vais monter
jusqu'au quatrième étage mais genre
d'ailleurs je vous le déconseille
pour des questions évidentes on sait
jamais où de chaque couche je peux bien
sûr
j'arrivais déjà du bouche à bouche mais
non
c'est dit moi j'ai eu et j'ai été témoin
d'un accident de moto et comme j'avais
jeu comme j'ai passé mon brevet de
secouriste comme un gant parce que voilà
il fallait le passé j'ai donc mis là les
personnes en pls qui était en fait un
petit peu dans les vapes et quand elle a
ouvert les yeux qu'elle m'a reconnu m'a
dit ça y est je suis au paradis
je vous jure que je voulais alors je
suis ni mitonné ringard cette personne
chante en contact avec abel absolument
c'est un gars et on échange absolument
bah oui moi je suis aéro bondit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de premiers secours et du brevet de
secourisme je trouve qu'on n'est pas
suffisant mais moi je suis face à une
situation où quelqu'un se sent pas bien
fait un malaise franchement je ne sais
pas comment agir je ne sais pas faire un
massage cardiaque je ne sais pas faire
de bouches à nourrir leur trouve que
c'est assez délicat en france de ne pas
savoir faire ça rendra pas une école
vide est en fête l'été on peut le passer
on
peut le passer maintenant chez les
jeunes
je vous conseille alors dans le genre
héros à arras est un héros un peu
différent je vous explique on est en
australie et à monsieur se promène avec
son avec son petit chien carrosserie il
ya beaucoup de kangourou est moins
conséquent et donc le chien va c'est
après par le congo est l'homme à vouloir
sauver son chien souffre le kangourou
vous savez ce que ça fait qu'en gros on
a beau faire
le garde banks il a fait ça passe de lui
comme ça et vous allez voir ça fait pour
vous
[Rires]
il
est
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va quand même devoir parce qu'il y va
il y va franchement alors c'est je tiens
à préciser que c'est paraît-il la seule
méthode voilà reconnu pour pour
affronter le congo c'est se mettre
devant lui et il fait dire madame genre
je vais te mettre une passat et
c'est fou mais ce n est là c'est qu'on
bourre on alors alors ce n'est pas de la
maltraitance en fait c'est la seule
façon chair naturels
le kangourou on doit l'affronter comme
ça et bien lieu et une droite genre
bîmes
genou mais
c'est normal y'a que vous pour garder
les gouttelettes de côté
parce qu'un coup de patte du congo peut
vous tuer ouais ouais bien sûr vraiment
fâché c'est pour ça qu'il faut se mettre
en avant et lui faire face c'est ce que
j'ai fait moi dernièrement avec avec une
autre personne qui n'est pas content